- Ian's gonna come by.
- Your friends were
really cool last night.
I really like that dude, Sam.
- His name is Anthony, you
were calling him Sam all night.
- Oh, I didn't register
and of your guys' names.
It was Jenna and Tyler?
Um, Monica and Sam, cool good meeting ya.
- Actually, Anthony.
- You do this, you're horrible at names.
- I can really connect
to somebody so fast,
- Yeah, you're good, dude.
you're a good friend, Sam.
The boy, Sam.
Sam, Sam, the garbageman, boom!
- It is Anthony.
- Well, he looked like a Sam, okay?
- What?
- I really like that girl Andrea, too.
- There was no Andreas at the party.
- Alyssa? Melissa?
- You gotta get better at this.
- I'm a faces guy, you know.
- What?
- I remember faces, not names.
- What does that even mean?
Are there people walking
around that are good at names
and not faces?
- Sure.
- So, they're walking around
with catalogs of names
and they don't have any
face to put to them?
- I don't know.
- That doesn't even make sense.
It's just a bad excuse for
being bad at names, dude.
- I don't even...
- Do you want to learn, or not?
Do you want to get better at this or not?
When someone gives me their name,
- (in slow motion) Anthony.
- I say back to them.
(slow motion) Anthony?
So not only have I heard
it, but I've said it.
(very slow motion)An-tho-ny.
- (slow motion) Yeah.
You see what I'm saying?
You get it?
- Okay.
- Yeah?
- So it's like, I'm Chris.
- I'm Jared.
- I'm Chris.
- No, it's, you know Chris,
you have to say Jared.
- Okay, I'll try it on
the next person I meet.
I'll somebody right now.
- All right.
- I'll just get a person walking by.
- Chris, don't do this, Chris that's.
- Hey man, I'm Chris.
- Yeah, I know, I met
you last night, dude.
- That's Ian.
- I guess I'm not a faces guy, either.
- Doing anything tomorrow?
- Perfect, dude, we got another bruncher.
- Ha.
- We brunch pretty
hard, I'm not gonna lie.